pour détailler ces annonces à ses
nombreuses notre chroniqueur
international gauthier rybinski est avec
nous en plateau rongeurs gothique
bonjour antoine beaucoup d'annoncés
retenir de cette prise de parole à la
fois d'ursula von der leyen et du chef
de la diplomatie européenne josep
borrell on va on va peut-être commencer
avec vous gauthier sur le sait les étés
au tout début de leur annonce l'union
européenne dans son ensemble c'est une
annonce de la dure cela vandaele va donc
financer l'achat et la livraison d'armes
à l'ukraine et ça c'est ce qu'ils disent
est en tout cas c'est une première oui
c'est une première parce que il s'agit
de la livraison d'armes létales
malheureusement on en est là c'est à
dire des armes qui tuent jusqu'à présent
l'union européenne se réserver le droit
donc au sein de son instance de
favoriser ou de fournir des équipements
de secours ou des équipements de défense
et vous souvenez qu'il n'ya pas
longtemps c'était il ya une dizaine de
jours certains avaient souri en
apprenant que l'allemagne avait décidé
de fournir à l'armée ukrainienne des
casques les casques donc militaire de
défense b ça voulait bien dire la
différence signifier la différence entre
armes l'état des armes non létales là
pour la première fois de son existence
l'europe effectivement autorise la
livraison d'armes létales c'est à dire
pour se battre ça n'a l'air de rien
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'elle ait
le là là discret pense entre le pouvoir
militaire de poutine et celui de
l'ukraine mais c'est une révolution là
aussi copernicienne de la même manière
que l'annoncé par l'allemagne de la
modification substantielle de son budget
de défense est aussi une révolution cela
veut dire qu'il ya une prise de
conscience tout lente et bien tarder il
met une prise de conscience sur l'idée
qu une europe qui n'est pas capable
d'agir militairement ce n'est pas une
europe efficace n'est pas une europe
utile
gauthier un mot avec vous rapidement le
ursula von der leyen et josette borel
qui ont également ciblé la biélorussie
également le régime de daleh d'alexandre
loukachenko a accusé d'être d'être
complice qui le font prison promille
encore de nouvelles sanctions pour
éviter que la russie qu'on tourne
finalement les sanctions mises en place
déjà alors oui ça sert à empêcher que la
russie contournent ces sanctions via la
biélorussie mais c'est aussi
probablement un argument tactique et
politique qui consisterait à faire
pression sur le dictateur biélorusse qui
est lui d'un esprit assez fantasque et
on a vu qu'il était capable de dire tout
son contraire et en même temps de
revenir au point de départ donc il
s'agirait là de presser la biélorussie
pour qu'elle soit de nature à ne pas
coller jusqu'au bout on va adhérer
jusqu'au bout ou aux menées et à l'aider
l'idéologie de vladimir poutine c'est
une tentative donc de découpler une
partie de l'adversaire merci beaucoup
god